[Music]
good morning everybody it's seven
o'clock in the uk very welcome to spend
your breakfast with us here at sky news
this morning the government's all fired
up with a promise of an agreement to cut
the global use of coal but some of the
nations who burn the most
aren't yet on board meanwhile at
westminster temperatures are rising in
the row over conservative mps voting to
protect their colleague owen patterson
from being suspended plenty to ask the
business secretary quasi quatering about
in just a few moments also this morning
for you the prime minister of the
beautiful south pacific microstate of
tuvalu tells us how climate change is
devastating his country and in addition
to that the woman who's seen the world
through the windows of the international
space station and now fights to protect
the planet the former nasa astronaut
nicole stott will be with us on the
programme it's thursday the 4th of
november the heat is on the government
claims it secured a new agreement to
phase out coal but some of the biggest
producing countries haven't yet signed
up
australia is one of the biggest mining
nations on earth but it doesn't appear
keen to reduce the amount of coal it
produces
and i'm here in india a country that
relies on coal to keep the lights on
where there is no clear plan or
commitment to phase it out anytime soon
cries of corruption growing anger after
conservative mps vote to protect the
former cabinet minister owen patterson
from being suspended
scientists warn coveted rates in england
are now amongst the highest levels ever
recorded
and after 12 years of record lows could
interest rates be on the way up today
[Music]
morning on day five of the cop 26 summit
in glasgow the government is unveiling
what it calls a milestone agreement to
phase out coal power but there's concern
that some of the biggest mining nations
and coal-burning countries aren't part
of the deal
190 countries and organizations have
agreed to the phasing out of coal power
and the end of support for new coal
power plants
an end to all investments in new coal
power generation both domestically and
internationally to rapidly increase the
use of clean power and a plan to phase
out coal power for the world's major
economies in the 2030s with the rest of
the world to follow by the 2040s
lots to talk about then
from glasgow the business secretary
quasi quatting is with us this morning
mr cotting thank you for very much
indeed for joining us on the program
this morning i mean this looks fantastic
in theory but not everybody signed up to
it including some of the uh major uses
of coal how long is that going to take
i think uh it may it means that we've
made huge progress uh on this subject um
only last year we said that we weren't
going to invest
in overseas uh coal mining
uh this year as you say just uh today we
will unveil the fact that uh about 190
uh countries and organizations are going
to be signed up uh to phasing out coal
um and across the world people realize
that uh coal
is going to be a thing of the past we're
consigning coal to history so i think
it's a really impressive step
yeah but china and u.s not signed up is
that right
well we're working with uh chinese
negotiators
as well as the united states and of
course you know that the united states
certainly under president biden is
taking its climate commitments
extremely seriously
and even in china
they've announced that they're not going
to be investing in overseas uh coal
mining so that's a big step obviously we
want to go further but i don't think we
should play down the significance
of of today's announcements okay what's
going to happen to the new white haven
coal mine
uh that as i always say is a planning
issue it's not something which uh i can
determine as a as a secretary of state
and it's going to be reviewed it is
being reviewed by the relevant planning
authority
yeah but if we're saying the end of curl
is in sight obviously we don't want to
work in more coal mines do we
no but we've had a huge success
uh in moving away from coal uh really
only in the last 10 years
uh in 2012
40 of our electricity was from coal
today it's only one percent
um and as far as that particular coal
mine is concerned as i've said uh that's
something which is uh part of an
independent planning process
yeah but you appreciate that if we're
saying that the end of cole is in sight
which is a quote that we're using this
morning what the government's saying and
then talking about opening a new coal
mine i mean the juxtaposition of those
two is not going to sit comfortably with
my viewers this morning is it
now understand uh your point but as i
keep saying
as far as the coal uh
mining cumbria was concerned that was a
process that was started uh some years
ago and at the moment it's something
that's an independent uh planning
decision and it would not be right for
me as a minister uh to comment on the on
the rights and wrongs of it
don't see why not
well it's an independent process so what
happens is that you have people like me
ministers making
political policy uh uh calls and then if
you have a planning uh situation it's
often goes through the relevant planning
authority and if there's an appeal that
is an independent process and at the
moment it's currently being investigated
so it wouldn't be right for me to say
one way or the other what i think is
going to happen
okay
so the government abides by independent
process
a tory mp
is paid 500 000 pounds
by two companies to lobby on their
behalf
he's found guilty because it's against
the rules
he's suspended from parliament for 30
days
the ruling conservative party you guys
vote to change the rules why
so it wasn't uh it's not about the
rights and wrongs of what owen patterson
uh said or did or or how he was paid i
think the process is something that we
want to look at the fact is he had no uh
right of appeal and we feel that in
terms of parliament um people should
have a right of appeal as they do
uh in most employments uh throughout
this country so as far as i know because
i've been here all week as you
appreciate as far as i know and i've
read the issue about the issue and been
told about it um the vote yesterday was
all about you know getting a proper
process
and getting some sort of right of appeal
that mps of all parties uh can rely on
uh in in a case like this it's not about
the rights and wrongs of what owen did
or didn't do
it's about trying to get it to know it's
about trying to get for no no it isn't
about
the the the andrew i mean i read the
what uh andrea ledson's amendment was
about and that was all about you know
setting up a committee and setting up a
right of appeal process
uh in a in a case like this i don't
think it was particularly related to
uh what
owen said or did
it took half a million quid to lobby on
behalf of two companies which are
against the rules as a result the
independent body which you say you abide
by independent thought um has decided
that he has to be suspended for 30 days
half a million pounds people are
struggling to feed their kids he takes
half a million quid and you you move the
goal posts
so as i said okay it's the vote
yesterday and i wasn't there but i've
read about it the vote yesterday you're
closer to it
you're closer to it than i am frankly oh
stop it
stop it i mean i'm in glasgow i'm in
glasgow geographically i might be closer
but you know exactly what's going on
that that's duplicitous to say that
minister come on no no it's not they i
mean looking at what happened yesterday
and i read the motion and i saw
bits of the debate it was it was all
about the process the vote was about
getting a system of fairness
back
into
almost what might be a kind of
employment uh tribunal i mean my
department looks after employment
tribunal looks after workers rights and
throughout this country people would
have any employee would have a right of
appeal this is something that owen
doesn't have didn't have and we're
trying to get that back into the
parliamentary process i'm not here to
comment on what he did or how much money
he was making or anything like that i
think there was an issue with the
process i think the system had broken
down
and we want to reform it
have you ever taken money for promoting
uh a company's product
no i haven't i'm a minister so why would
you not well i'm a minister
in the government so
rules against just a clarification um if
the government are so concerned about uh
standards process uh why is it changing
the rules 90 minutes
before on the very day that one of your
colleagues is being suspended if you
were so offended by the system why was
it not changed before no
so kay i mean you you'll appreciate i'm
sure that we've been talking about this
for years we've been talking about um
holding mps to account having the
highest standards uh in public life uh
ways in which we can improve uh those
standards and make people more
accountable we've been talking about
these sorts of things for for many years
now and it and and it so happens that
yesterday we uh passed a vote
narrow vote i think uh in favor of
actually trying to get a more rigorous
process where people would could have a
right of appeal and that's what uh my
understanding of what happened yesterday
in parliament what was all about
completely coincidental that it was the
same day that erin patterson was going
to be suspended for 30 days for uh
breaching the rules it's a dark day for
democracy says chris bryant 50
conservative mps agree and they divide
the three-line whip explaining to my
viewers a three-line whip is basically
when you are told that this is what you
have to do 50 conservative mps said i'm
sorry we're not having that how can you
defend the government on this one
well just just on that i mean 50 mps
were out but i was one of them so many
people were doing
uh other things they were doing um you
know government business lots of people
here at this world
conference um so it doesn't mean that
because 50 people didn't vote uh
yesterday
were you paired with the labels
why did you not vote just just explain
that to our viewers
because i i mean glasgow and were you
paired with it with a labor mp it wasn't
so that
really don't care at all what they care
about is that you're that the the
government was telling mps which way
they had to vote and your tory mps was
saying absolutely not this is
totally unacceptable and in fact when
the result came through many of them
were shouting shame do you feel shame
this morning
i don't feel shame at all i didn't see
the vote coming in
but it was an independent process it was
an independent vote at parliament
and i'm i'm really interested in seeing
the system uh reformed and made more
just and fair by allowing people a right
of appeal
uh not independent if it's whip though
is it
not look i don't know about that
okay you said you didn't want to talk
about it is it an independent vote or
not it's not an independent vote if it's
whip so it's not independent is it
well as you said lots of people didn't
vote lots of people a number of people
voted against the government
and it was a expressway of parliament
we're getting down in the weeds aren't
we here the point is this guy took half
a million quid for lobbying people he
shouldn't have done it he got he was
told that he had to be suspended for 30
days you moved the goal post so he
didn't have to um my viewers watching
this morning will think
sleaze sleaze
they may do but i don't think it's about
that at all i think it's about trying to
make sure that someone who's been
accused of something has a right of
appeal
okay new committee is what's being set
up labour and the snp
on the previous committee's so outraged
just saying that they're not going to
sit on this committee it's just not
not something that they want to do
it's not the right way for democracy
going forward you're still going to go
ahead with the committee
i think we won't i mean that was what
was expressed in the vote yesterday
i think there'll be a uh this morning i
have to say
what no i think look i think it was a
vote yesterday the house of commons made
its will expressed and we feel that
there needs to be a right of appeal for
any mp from any party uh that was in the
same situation uh who's been accused of
really quite serious uh serious
wrongdoing oh it is serious wrongdoing
yeah but
we've established that this is not about
what he did or didn't do it's about
trying to get a fair process uh the
public is concerned it's about what he
did and didn't do he took half a million
quid in order to influence uh the
government basically that's what he did
and the independent commission said
that's not acceptable that's what my
viewers are interested in this morning
further he then goes on to say i'd do it
again
owen patterson has a right as anyone
else does in any employment
to appeal against
a sentence or any kind of judgment
in in this instance he didn't have that
right of appeal the vote yesterday was
all about trying to get a fairer system
in place
he said that the commissioner should
resign do you think she should
i think it's difficult uh to see
what the future of the of the
commissioner is given the fact that
we're reviewing the process and we're
overturning
and trying to
reform uh this whole process but it's up
to the commissioner to decide her
position
so you think she should
resign
all i've said is that we're trying to
reform the process and i think that's
what i'm very focused on
as a parliament she should review her
position i think is what you said
it's up to her to do that i mean it's up
to anyone in the where they've made a
judgment and uh
people have sought uh to to change that
to consider their position that's a
natural thing but i'm not saying she
should uh she should resign
just before i let you go
what would you say to my viewers this
morning who say
tories with their noses in the trough
again
i would say that
in their employment in their workplace
if they were accused of anything they
would expect a fair hearing and also
they would expect a right of appeal
and that all we're trying to do is to
bring that in are you saying it wasn't a
fair hearing in westminster are you
saying it wasn't a fair hearing
i'm saying that you would have a right
of appeal even if it was a fair hair
very entitled to a fair hearing are you
saying it wasn't a fair hearing you you
you would yeah i'm not i'm saying that
you're entitled to a fair hearing and
you're entitled to a right of appeal
why was it not fair here okay okay okay
what i'm trying to say is that he did
not have a right of appeal you accept
that and that's why i don't accept that
no i don't accept that at all i also i'm
challenging you on whether you're saying
it was a fair here it's not a fair
hearing you know it was a hearing that
went on for a significant amount of time
we know that it went on a little longer
than potentially it might have been
because of sad personal circumstances
that mr patterson um had to deal with
but he was able to speak to the hearing
there was an opportunity for written
testimony from all sorts of witnesses
all of that was taken into account and
then the independent committee decided
that on balance um he'd taken money that
he shouldn't have taken or certainly
shouldn't have been campaigning for
those businesses given that he had taken
money and as a result he needed to be
suspended for 30 days uh 90 minutes
before that the government that they're
going to change the rules so that he
doesn't have to be those are the
headlines
so as i've said uh repeatedly on this
program he did not have a right of
appeal and you've accepted that and
that's what the critical point is and
that's why the vote happened yesterday
and it was it was passed
and you're completely comfortable with
that decision this morning minister
you're completely comfortable with that
i'm comfortable with uh the vote in the
house of commons because that's how
parliamentary democracy works
okay i think you might be asked this a
few times this morning so i better let
you go thank you very much indeed for
joining us on the programme this morning
uh
we'll be talking about that in more
detail i'm sure with labour at the top
of the next hour but for now let's
return to cole sky news correspondent
katarina vittotsi
uh in kolkata in india and siobhan
robbins in moswell brook in australia
ladies good morning good morning sorry
to have kept you thank you uh for uh
bearing with us where shall we go first
let's go to australia first should we
with siobhan good morning uh siobhan so
we've got a new um agreement in place
but australia of course one of the
biggest uh
contributors as far as coal is concerned
in the whole world
and there's absolutely no suggestion
from people here that they will be doing
anything to reduce coal production i'm
in new south wales i'm actually in coal
country here the hills behind me are
dotted with mines you can see a massive
coal fired power station behind me as
well
but people here are really skeptical
about the cop announcement today they're
saying in this area alone in the hunter
valley around 100 000 people get money
from coal directly or indirectly and
they believe that if the tap is simply
turned off where will the money come
from they want a much clearer plan about
how people would move over from coal
they're also saying essentially if there
is a demand for coal then australia will
produce it they will sell it they are
the one of the biggest exporters of coal
in the world but this will come as a
massive concern to climate campaigners
around the world that australia hasn't
stepped up it hasn't
joined this coal pledge it hasn't joined
the methane pledge it hasn't set any
clearer harder targets for emissions in
2030 and given the level of climate
climate crisis that the world is facing
many will be thinking is australia
really taking this seriously
okay and let's bring in katarina as well
who is in india of course they need coal
to keep the lights on in india katarina
yeah they do more than 60
of india's electricity electricity
generation comes from coal and really
it's been the elephant in the room
hasn't it throughout cop26 you had the
indian prime minister narendra modi on
monday being embraced and congratulated
by world leaders for upping their 2030
short-term targets for setting a date
for net zero 2017 you know far in the
more far in the future than perhaps they
would have liked but still
cole the elephant in the room the word
not mentioned by the indian prime
minister and really that's because it is
such a huge undertaking
for a transition away from coal for this
country as i said such a huge bulk of
its power comes from coal use it's the
world's second biggest importer of coal
uh senator siobhan saying in india there
are hundreds of thousands of jobs that
depend on coal both directly and
indirectly as well so it's a mammoth
task to try and start that phase out
really what is going to be what drives
it if there are any commitments on it is
india's own desire to try and reduce its
reliance on imported fossil fuels the
price of those we've seen in the past
few months considerably higher than they
were last year in the year before so
india will be conscious of that in the
short term we understand there will be
an increase actually in the domestic
production of coal about that reliance
on the foreign imports is something that
will be the driver rather than a wish to
please an international audience with
targets
let's leave it there thanks very much
for the update thanks a lot
still to come on the program for you
could more extreme weather be used to
power britain in the fight against
climate change that's the suggestion
from environmentalist chris packham who
joins us at half past seven
live with one couple heading to
australia as they prepare to see their
family for the first time in nearly two
years as kobe travel restrictions begin
to ease
and can labour derail the government's
plan to overrule the parliamentary
disciplinary process shadow women's
minister annelise dobbs joins us just
after eight o'clock
so can the coal agreement stand a chance
of being successful without china on
board our asia correspondent tom
cheshire reports
welcome to china's coal country
the impact of all this isn't just being
felt here but by the planet itself
coal is the dirtiest fossil fuel around
and china burns more of it than the rest
of the world combined and it's speeding
up we've taken a road trip to shenzhen
province north china to understand it
better
it's a place where almost everything is
caked in grime and soot but it's the
scale that's astonishing
we visit three coal power plants within
a few hours drive of each other
they're under construction or adding
extra power and between them alone
represent more coal power than the
entire uk output
and what's more they nearly weren't
built they were all halted a few years
ago under a national directive to
restrict coal power only to resume
construction
what this is is zombie coal power killed
off back in 2017 but now being brought
stumbling back to life ready to spew
harmful gases into the air and china
can't or won't kill it off for good
ningwoo town is attached to one of the
mines and heavily reliant on the
industry
people are too busy trying to survive
the coming winter to even know about
cop26
i'm waiting here by a school because
more people pass by
my whole family sells coal my son my
daughter and i we've sold coal our whole
lives
fanlau sir buys coal from nearby mines
and drives into town to sell it from the
back of his van to people here to burn
for heat
because of shortages and coal being
diverted to heavy industry mines have
less to spare sometimes he now has to
wait two days at the mine to fill up his
van we asked him what he thought of
china's climate emission targets and cop
26.
i don't know i'm busy every day i earn
my living by working outside all day
long
even chinese climate experts don't
believe it's practical for the country
to cut its co-dependence in the short
term
this isn't about the gap between pledges
and reality between high level
international summits and the truth on
the ground
this is the pledge the one china has
made officially to build more and more
coal power for the next four years and
then reduce it only gradually
they have not said how they will do that
or how long it will take
and in that uncertainty that hesitation
hangs the future of our climate tom
cheshire sky news shanxi china
for uninterrupted coverage of the summit
including special guests and analysis
you can watch sky news climate live on
channel 525 from 10 am
also making the news for you this
morning
police in australia say they believe a
man suspected of abducting four-year-old
cleo smith acted alone she was found in
a house in western australia more than
two weeks after she disappeared a 36
year old man is being questioned by
detectives
as you're aware there's a there's a man
in custody who may well be before the
court very shortly but we've seen the
physical condition that we can say so
she's been checked out at the hospital
and physically she's okay i can confirm
that that's
what we will allege that has taken place
that he acted solely alone
well police have released a short audio
recording of the moment cleo was found
i got it
hey bobby
come here
oh my goodness that's very dramatic
isn't it now scientists are warning that
covid rates in england are now at some
of the highest levels ever seen they say
infections are increasing fastest among
young children and also teenagers the
very latest figures show the uk has
recorded
41
299 new covered infections in the last
day
there have been a further 217 deaths
that brings a total number of deaths
reported within 28 days of a positive
test
to 140
964.
well let's speak to our reporter shaman
freeman powell who's going to update us
on that for us hello to you good morning
good morning um so figures are going up
good morning kay and yes they are so
this data has been done by react which
is a community testing program which
really focuses on home testing to get a
better understanding of how the pandemic
is progressing now it says that october
recorded the highest figure since may
2020 and that's when they first started
collecting this data but it is important
to mention though that they didn't
collect any data for december and if we
cast our minds back december was the
time that we all had to reconsider our
christmas plans because the rate of
infection was so high so it can't be
said that these figures beat that record
but it certainly can be said that they
are some of the highest figures that
we've seen so far now react says that
this has been driven by infection rates
in younger people between the ages of 5
and 12 and 13 to 17 and say that rates
got particularly high before the half
term but did slow down after those
school holidays so there is uh there is
some suggestion now that the rates are
going up um however there is a lot of
push and emphasis on these booster
vaccinations as this seems to be the
government's main way out it's also very
important to note that hospitalizations
and deaths are slower than some of the
other peaks but these figures do suggest
that the pandemic is not over just yet
okay thank you
could more extreme weather be used to
power britain in the fight against
climate change environmentalist chris
packham has the details we'll talk to
him next
[Music]
hello again the business secretary says
the decision to overturn disciplinary
findings against a senior conservative
mp was simply about reforming
parliamentary procedure to give him a
right of appeal owen patterson was found
to have misused his position to benefit
two companies he worked for quasi
quatting told me the vote had nothing to
do with mr patterson's guilt
or innocence
it's not about the rights and wrongs of
what owen patterson uh said or did or or
how he was paid i think the process is
something that we want to look at the
fact is he had no right of appeal and we
feel that in terms of parliament um
people should have a right of appeal as
they do
in most employments
throughout this country so as far as i
know because i've been here all week as
you appreciate as far as i know and i've
read the issue about the issue and been
told about it
the vote yesterday was all about you
know getting a proper process
and getting some sort of right of appeal
that mps of all parties
can rely on
well now in paterson was found to have
breached the rules following an
investigation by the parliamentary
standards commissioner that's katherine
stone
mr kwateng seemed to suggest that ms
stone should now consider her position
i think it's difficult
to see
what the future of the of the
commissioner is given the fact that
we're reviewing the process and we're
overturning
and trying to
reform
uh this whole process but it's up to the
commissioner to decide her position
so you think she should
resign
all i've said is that we're trying to
reform the process and i think that's
what i'm very focused on uh as a
parliamentarian she should review her
position i think is what you said
it's up to her to do that i mean it's up
to anyone in the where they've made a
judgment and uh
people have sought uh to to change that
to consider their position that's a
natural thing but i'm not saying she
should uh she should resign
uh tamara's here oh my goodness that was
squeaky bomb time wasn't it yes quasi
quartering drew the short straw this
morning having to defend this system
which many tory mps feel is indefensible
as you were putting to him dozens of
tory mps refused to vote for it and some
of them outright voted against it with
tory mps calling it a dark day for
democracy and a colossal misjudgment
quasi-cuateng and the government's
defense of changing the entire system on
the day that one of their own was
supposed to be suspended is that it
would create a new system with the right
of appeal and the right to call
witnesses now members of the committee
which looked at the owen patterson case
say that he was given masses of time to
put his case to them through lawyers and
they communicated with him back and
forth so he was able to put his case and
he was able to put it to parliament and
into the media as well you could also
say that what was set up yesterday in in
this of course this 90-minute debate
this huge change that came in was a new
committee with a conservative majority
although they talked about the right of
appeal they certainly didn't set up a
new system with that in it there was no
real discussion of how it would work so
all that is tbc really and that's why
labor today really going on the attack
saying they're saying this is corruption
this is rigging the system the question
for labor though now is they say they
won't cooperate with it they're going to
boycott this new system but
traditionally these standard systems
have been set up cross-party the system
we've got now was set up after the cash
for questions scandal in 1995. so if
labor won't cooperate with it what is
the future of this new system given that
the independent standards commissioner
who looked into the case catherine stone
has said that she's not resigning she's
staying in her post even though i
thought it was um notable that quasi
cuatin said it was difficult to see what
future she had
he also said it didn't didn't actually
matter that owen patterson had broken
the rules and taken half a million quid
well what the government's position is
that this is not about the rights and
wrongs of the owen paterson case this is
about setting up a new committee to look
at it and in terms of that it was on the
same day yes exactly that's the
difficulty but in theory this committee
with a tory majority could look at it
and find that he did break the rules and
give him the same sanction so they're
not taking a judgment on that of course
even owen patterson's friends who defend
him like suburna jenkins for example a
tory mp who was on the standards
committee but didn't sat out this
inquiry because of their friendship said
it looks terrible to be doing it on the
same day if you want to overhaul the
standard system do this case first and
then look at it later but boris johnson
went ahead with it and he has a big
majority and he perhaps calculated that
he could get it through and people would
not be that bothered because the public
might be more concerned about what's
going on in their own lives but
certainly the strength of the the
reaction i think may have surprised some
in government let's see what happens
next for now tomorrow thank you
could the great british weather help
fight climate change we love to moan
about how sunny and windy it gets but
now environmentalists say those very
things could provide our much needed
clean energy going forward how let's
find out with the broadcaster and
environmental campaigner chris packham
who's joining us hi chris thanks for
joining us on the programme this morning
we've seen wind turbines we've seen wind
farms a lot here in the united kingdom
but actually the power that they are
supplying is increasing all the time now
isn't it it's not just oh look there's a
wind farm
no the power is increasing that they
supply uh largely down to their rollout
and also improvements in technology
i think we have to recognize that wind
turbines and solar panels have moved on
tremendously in the time that we've
become aware of their existence and that
technology is making them more
affordable
and delivering more energy more quickly
the thing is we've got to get that
energy from those often remote locations
when farms are up here in scotland most
of them are up on the peatlands of
scotland solar farms are most productive
in in the west country where it is
sunniest of of course for most of the
time we've got to get that energy
through our grid and into our homes and
therefore what we need to
exercise these renewables make them more
worthwhile is a smarter more flexible
energy system so smart energy gb are
rolling out their smart meters and
trying to get them into as many homes as
possible 24 million are already out
there not just about improving the way
that we use energy in the home but
feedbacking information about that
energy when it's used how it's used so
that we can better distribute it and
improve efficiency and therefore make
sure that we can cut back on our
dependence on fossil fuels fuels coal
and gas energy
and also storing that energy once it's
been created because of course it's not
windy all the time
it isn't windy well it's not windy all
the time in all places but being on the
edge of the continent as we are as you
pointed out at the outset we are in one
of the best places to harness that sort
of energy and i think you'd always find
someone in the uk perhaps complaining
about the level of wind or sun or
whatever it happens to be but you're
right it's about making sure that we
have a network of these abilities to
generate these renewable energies in the
right places and distribute that energy
as battery technology improves and again
that technology is uh
improving the pace then we would need to
be storing that energy i think that in
that instance we're looking at a lot
more local storage it could be at some
stage in the future if we can improve
those batteries that that could be um we
could done it even at a domestic or or
local community level but at this point
in time we've got to use the
infrastructure that we've got and we've
got to improve it and it needs to be
smarter
you know we are effectively wasting
fossil fuel energy by letting it get
clogged up and distributed inefficiently
and that's why we need these better
systems of technology to to create as i
said that smart flexible
modern energy distribution system
tell me about your movie or film uh the
weather energy report
whether energy report was commissioned
with cambridge university i i think we
need to know what the public want from
their energy uh the the heartening thing
was that a significant percentage of
people questioned at the outset said
that they were worried about climate
change um sometimes campaigners such as
myself think that it's just us it's just
we're in a bit of a bubble but it's good
to see that 76 of the public say they do
have concerns about the impact of this
on their lives therefore they will be
aligned with us in trying to seek
improvements um no question there but
equally unsurprising given the current
crises that we've seen running into this
autumn and winter nearly 90 percent of
people are worried about prices of
energy too so we've got to make sure
that we can generate affordable energy
get it into people's homes and at the
same time address these colossal issues
which we are confronting we've heard
this morning that nations are saying
that they want to give up on coal we
will have to move through a transition
that's not something that's going to
happen overnight and as we move as
hopefully as rapidly through that
transition as possible we need to bring
these other forms of energy generation
online and make sure that they're
serving people keeping prices down and
that they offer a secure energy system
for the uk
chris just before i let you go you were
recently a victim of an awful arson
attack at uh at your home you're not
going to allow that to stop you uh
campaigning are you
i'm not no i suppose it's like
terrorism okay we we can't any of us
give in to it it's a blight upon our
lives and we have to find the energy the
determination and the ambition to to
rise above it and carry on at this point
in time the things i think i'm
campaigning about about that might have
elicited this attack i still believe to
be true and right and therefore i will
continue to proceed
pursue them with as much gus though as i
possibly can good of you to take the
time to speak to us this morning chris
thank you pleasure kay thank you
thank you well despite the rising gas
prices there's one part of the uk which
has more energy than it needs
orkney has more than 650 wind turbines
and thousands of solar panels generating
130 percent of the electricity needed as
our science correspondent thomas morneau
reports
at the tip of scotland there is a
treasure island where renewable energy
is the new gold
very traditional sort of one room one
room that's it really
adrian bird has lived on chapensay for
15 years he took us in one of the
islands electric vans to the wind
turbine that's owned by the community
and generates up to 5 000 pounds a day
money that funds a bus an out of hours
ferry and affordable housing this is our
turbine so we're doing something
positive for the community but we're
also taking advantage of clean renewable
electricity to do that
there are more than 600 turbines on
orkney capitalizing on the abundant wind
producing far more electricity than the
islands need but the power cable back to
the mainland gets overloaded and the
energy companies can throttle back the
energy they generate they're going to
put the brakes on now so you can see
they slowed us right down that must be
hugely frustrating because that's lost
money it is it's a huge loss of money it
will take a while for turbine to get
back up and running properly again this
can happen 100 times a day
but now chapensay is turning the excess
power into hydrogen energy once wasted
is in effect stored as a gas to use
later
this is the island school and for
decades it's been heated by oil oil that
was burned in three boilers in here and
of course that oil came from a long way
away and result in large amounts of
emissions now
it's got six hydrogen boilers the
hydrogen made up of the wind turbine
it's local energy and the only byproduct
is water
adele is the climate change officer for
orkney council she says the islands show
the rest of the uk how to live without
electricity generated by fossil fuels
we've got hundreds of households with a
wind turbines we've got hundreds of
households now using electric vehicles
we generate more than 100 of our own
need of electricity from renewables so
there hasn't been you know a lifestyle
change for us
40 minutes off the coast they're
experimenting with a so far untapped
source of energy the tide
the orbital o2 is the most powerful
turbine of its kind with rotors that
spin in the water rushing between the
atlantic and north sea scaled up
turbines like this could supply more
than 10 percent of the uk's electricity
with the same guaranteed output as gas
or coal the tides are very very
predictable we can look into the future
and tell you at any time what the tides
are going to be doing so we're able to
to know how much power and when that
power is going to be coming into the uk
grid to keep the lights on in a net zero
world we will need a mix of renewable
sources of energy but orkney shows the
way
and it works thomas more sky news in
kirkwall
more from cop 26 coming up very shortly
indeed but first thousands of people
with relatives in australia are now able
to see their families for the first time
in nearly two years many are heading
down under this morning for what will be
an emotional
reunion amongst them are yvonne and
kevin king leaving from heathrow to see
their daughter and grandson hello to you
both
hi hi hi how lovely to see you now it's
when have you actually seen your
grandson in person yet
no no
he was born october 20 during lockdown
and his first birthday last week and
we've missed it all
oh so what's the first what's the plan
what's the first thing you're going to
do when you get there yvonne
um
to get to see him and to be there and
play with you and
you know do everything it's just it's
gonna be amazing
we've waited so long we get [ __ ]
flights
and things like that
yeah we've waited a long time
yeah absolutely kevin um with successive
lockdowns um that australia has had just
looking at the baby there as we're
talking to you uh you must have thought
this day would never come
well i'm the pessimist in the family and
uh i didn't think it was going to be
until something like april next year so
everything's changed in the last two or
three weeks with opening up sydney
um no hope quarantine
and the change in the first november big
section process
lovely you mentioned chris christmas
there kevin yvonne how long are you
planning to stay
um we're staying through until december
27th um returning to this nice sister 21
or 20 minutes
and kevin before i let you go how are
you feeling about the flight it's a long
way isn't it
we've done australia a number of times
but we've never done the 17 hours direct
to australia
that'll be a new experience but we'll
get through it because it's a good
reward at the end okay top tips drink
lots and lots of water get up and walk
around as often as you can and have a
fantastic time when you get there enjoy
christmas with your new grandson and
hopefully um we'll see when you get back
thank you for joining us
thank you very much
same flight thank you safe flight
so the world is opening up again uh
coming up in the nine o'clock hour gonna
be speaking to claire oven uh who is the
travel editor at the daily telegraph
she's just back from bermuda get her
fancy pants
also from next week i think we can fly
to
new york for the first time in many many
many months talking about that as well
also how ethical business advisors have
been virtually cycling to glasgow for
cop 26
latest on that coming up
[Music]
do
[Music]
and now it's coming from both sides
and it's moving this way
clearly not had very much to eat at all
a lot of them extremely thin and very
frail
the people here are praying
quietly to themselves
i'm alex crawford and i'm skye's special
correspondent based in istanbul
[Music]
now they're trying to finish the job off
so that they can move into the square
[Music]
okay it's okay don't worry it's
becoming okay sensitive
having the media around
they have no protective masks or
protective equipment at all
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place in the news
every time they touch and they spray
sprayed spray
[Music]
this is the cocktail of drugs which the
doctors at this hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients
made for people who want clarity in an
uncertain world
to the vineyards
i can't imagine
how much plastic
is lying at the bottom of this huge lake
[Music]
[Applause]
did you know that if we make small
changes to our lives we can reduce air
pollution by loads but how much exactly
loads
they'll be a mostly dry and quite sunny
morning but eastern and western coastal
counties can expect showers they will
become largely confined to western wales
cornwall and norfolk by midday it will
stay rather chilly with a raw wind in
the east whales will see showers mostly
dying out during the afternoon there'll
be little change elsewhere but the far
north will turn damp later on clean
north atlantic air means air pollution
levels will remain low with values
between 1 and 3 on the daily air quality
index
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
protesters have been and campaigners i
should say have been cycling walking and
marching to glasgow to make their voices
heard in the climate change debate one
firm decided to take on the challenge
and then turn it into a company health
initiative with us to talk about it in
more detail matt rooney from the
emphasis group who took on the challenge
to ride to cop hi thanks for joining us
on the program this morning uh tell us
about your colleagues cycle to glasgow
and why they did it
yeah sure good morning 2k yeah so none
of my colleagues they they rode from
various offices all over the country um
so london bristol oxford manchester uh
with part of the the ride change group
so about 170 or so other individuals all
hopped on their bikes made it through
some of the really challenging where
they're obviously very fitting given the
purpose they were going for
and made it all the way up to up to
glasgow but as you say it was part of a
wider
initiative that anthesis um
were running to promote better physical
and mental well-being so
some of our colleagues in other offices
around the world could also join in
and
they they were trying to hit the
combined distance of all of our offices
going to cop which is about 65 000
kilometers uh which i i believe we just
about hit so uh yeah hats off to
colleagues who definitely deserve a bit
more credit for me for their for their
pains uh
tell me about the anthesis group what do
you do
sure so yeah and thesis we're a
sustainability activator which means
that we're really looking to drive and
enable and activate real impact with a
lot of organizations that we work with
on the topic of sustainability and
climate change so we're the largest
group of dedicated uh professionals we
work with about 25 of the ftse 100
along with smes and
different layers of government um and
again it's all about the impact so
really to illustrate that point we
recently set a target to try and help
our clients remove and reduce uh their
carbon footprints by three gigatons
which is a pretty sizable number it's
roughly about half of the us's annual
emissions or eight times the uk's
emissions um and and also we have
recently become a certified b corp which
um is not something you do likely with
legally obligated to hit the highest
possible standards of social
environmental performance
to really make sure that we're we're
practicing what we preach
and in addition to all of that your
clients include 25 of the ftse 100 index
huge companies are they doing their fair
share to start to combat climate change
yeah so certainly certainly a mixed bag
um yeah we we're still seeing you know
different levels of maturity with with
clients you know certainly some some
leaders in there but i mean the proof is
is really in the pudding as you'll see
from a lot of the stats that have been
published over over recent weeks there's
certainly a lot more uh that companies
can can be doing
um
what are you hoping for from cop what do
you want to see
sure so i think it takes takes a couple
of forms really i mean i think
definitely you know no no no getting
away from i think you know the the stick
of of policy uh and keeping that keeping
that ambition high and keeping keeping
the pressure on other countries that
aren't necessarily setting the right the
right targets you know if you're not
setting the right targets you're you're
on to a bit of an on start there so i
think policy has a has a big role to
play i think you know we've seen a real
boom in demand um from the the finance
sector and the investment sector so
another type of stick but not
necessarily coming from policy coming
from folks that hold the purse strings
and they can say to their companies you
know we want you
to tell us how you're doing we want you
to tell us where the risks are and we
want you to to really demonstrate your
your your performance improvement so i
think you know that that side of it you
know
you know we're looking for for some real
sort of progress there and starting to
see you know bits and some good
announcements yesterday with um you know
better reporting and disclosures require
required but then i think on the you
know incentive side what incentives can
can can business see and i think that
for me comes down to really helping make
it easy for businesses to to get on that
journey to
avoid reduce remove emissions and you
know can feel i'm sure quite quite
overwhelming for many that are just sort
of new to this um so i think
being able to to show the real value
that this has and actually it's it's in
a lot of businesses commercial interest
to to do this and do this soon
sadly we're out of time that but it's
great to talk to you thanks very much
indeed for taking the time to join us on
the program this morning much
appreciated thank you coming up in the
next hour
the government what have they been up to
this time
[Music]